welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show taking your calls at eight five
five two three six thirty two twenty
eight that's eight five five and two
three six thirty two twenty eight be in
Wyoming you're on the bench FBI shot go
for B hi I'm so earlier today I was
chatting in a debate group with some
folks in the UK in Canada and they said
the quality of life is better there than
in the u.s. one of them actually used to
be a US citizen they argued that there's
less poverty better education and that
they also prefer the health care systems
in their country a number of Americans
joined in and they seem to strongly
agree so I'm quite outnumbered I'm just
curious how you would respond okay so so
a few things that are that are fairly
obvious the United States does have a
significantly larger GDP per capita than
Canada Canada has about forty six
thousand dollars per capita the United
States is about sixty three thousand
dollars per capita which is a
significantly larger sum as far as
health care you sort of have to
determine what you want you want
immediate access to the surgeries that
you want you know in nine times a
pandemic do you do you want the ability
to try treatments that you wouldn't
otherwise be able to get do you want a
rationed care system are you most
worried about emergency care without
having insurance that that is a question
of choice so I would prefer to live in a
system where I have insurance and where
my insurance means that I can basically
get what I need on demand at any time
right there's a reason people travel
from Canada to the United States for
surgery they don't travel from the
United States to Canada or the United
States to the UK as part of the
educational system it depends on where
you are talking about so if you're
talking about the university system the
United States blows away Canada blows
away the UK we have easily the best
university system on planet earth it is
not particularly close and if you look
at the lower education system you have
to really determine which area you are
talking about because the fact is that
the the that is really not a question so
much of our the teachers worse in
certain areas of the United States than
other areas of the United States or a
question of mere funding it's a question
of parental structure how much time are
parents spending with their kids on
homework it's a question of how much
time our parent spend with their kids
learning to read education is nearly
always a function of familial structure
and areas where parents spend a lot of
time with their kids on education the
schooling tends to be almost a secondary
concern as far as sort of quality of
life and ease of living if you're
talking about the availability of
government benefits there's more
availability of government benefits
in places like Canada there's more
available availability of government
benefits in places like UK if you're
talking about the opportunity for
entrepreneurship for making something of
yourself in building your own business
leading a freer life than the United
States is obviously better so it depends
what you're looking for
and it depends on whether you feel like
you're integrating in a community that
you that you've found people that you
share values with it's it's very hard to
compare apples to oranges especially
when you're talking about like if you
look at countries that say they're happy
countries in Norway Denmark Sweden very
very high levels of social compatibility
and social fabric also extremely
monochromatic the very little diversity
in a lot of those societies and so
everybody sort of thinks in similar
fashion because there's a lot of
commonality and shared background in
areas of more diversity there's you get
more diversity that's definitely an
upside it's also you know the
possibility for more conflict so again
you get to choose but it depends on the
metrics that you are using if you're
using objective metrics like where are
you most able to make a lot of money
where are you most able to live free
where are you most able to practice your
religion without interference by the
government all right those are all
values to me the United States blows
away Canada and the UK on all of those
metrics if you are looking for
government largesse then probably you
should look for a place that is that
it's not the United States or you know
travel yourself over to Massachusetts or
California okay so again it all depends
on metrics and definitions are a pretty
key here so really appreciate the call
see Mark in Israel you're on the bench
Bureau sure go for it mark hi Ben yeah
I've heard your colleagues speak in the
past about the virtues of the Crusades
how it was really a military response to
a Muslim oppression and trade issues I
was wondering if you can give a Jewish
perspective on that well I mean so
here's here's the thing nothing that
happens on planet earth is generally
good for the Jews like a couple thousand
years right between the between the
destruction of the Second Temple and the
establishment of the State of Israel
things don't go so hot for the Jews just
historically speaking the Crusades were
very bad for the Jews a lot of Christian
armies that were moving from Europe over
into the Middle East would slaughter
Jews on their way the the Muslim
treatment of Jews at the time was
generally better than the Christian
treatment of Jews at the time but again
that changes over time so it's it's not
as though if the Crusades had never
happened then the Jews would have been
significantly better off because it
turns out that the Muslims ended up
taking over the exact area that the the
Christians were holding for a couple of
centuries in the middle of the Crusades
in terms of the Middle East things
didn't end up going so hot for the Jews
there either so from the Jewish
perspective history basically looks like
things are you know topsy-turvy for
about a thousand years for about 1,200
years and then things suck radically for
almost two millennia and then things
start to get a lot better
starting post-world War two and that is
the brief story of Jewish history in a
nutshell mark if I could throw an idea
out there for an election night joint
livestream of the top three networks
that would be the Daily wire cast the
bill Whittle team and a ladder with
Crowder crew that BK and BK will
probably do some of that we did that
last election cycle bill bill stop by on
2016 it was a fun and and obviously
ladder with Crowder Skyped in so what
we'll probably end up doing something
like that appreciate the appreciate the
be following and and also appreciate you
you listening to to the show alrighty so
meanwhile I got some bad news here's an
article from The Jerusalem Post that
suggests that in fact the coronavirus
may not be susceptible to a vaccine
which is just the reason obviously that
is a bad thing is that everybody is sort
of suggesting that a vaccine is going to
fix all of this and maybe that this is
just the background to normal life
then now coronavirus is the new normal
and we are going to just have to deal
with that we're gonna have to deal with
the increased risk in American life that
overtime herd immunity will be developed
because that is the only that is the
only counter to a vaccine long term
writer treatments or herd immunity
that's it those are the only three
options vaccine herd immunity treatment
if vaccines are off the table treatment
is on the table and we are working
toward treatments steadily and herd
immunity is just enough people get it
that at that point basically everybody
has developed antibodies for this thing
the problem is that if it's not
susceptible to a vaccine then herd
immunity may not work great either
simply because the the the virus may
mutate and then you have a flu vaccine
that is only you know 60% effective and
herd immunity is only a certain percent
effective so all of
is is just wonderful wonderful stuff
this is uh the you know bad news but
we're gonna have to make some hard
decisions and anybody who suggests that
hard decisions do not have to be made
that these are all easy decisions is
lying to you but there are gonna be
risks that are going to be rewards there
is no easy answer here there is no world
in which this thing just sort of
disappears and we all go back to normal
in the very near future we're gonna have
to just deal with the fact that there's
increased risk in life and then we're
gonna have to figure out how to transfer
populations back into the workforce and
protect people who are vulnerable this
is the Ben Shapiro show